- So, yesterday I went to
school and I wore my hair
in an Afro like this.
And, a lot of people
had a lot of mean things
to say about it,
so, that made me feel some type of way.
I told my mom, and she said,
"Promise, don't forget who
you are, and whose you are."
And I said, "Okay."
So today I'm gonna go to school
and I'm gonna come back bigger and better,
and don't let anyone steal your joy.
Don't give them that much power.
- I'm so proud of you, that's so cool
that you flipped it, you
turned it into a positive.
You turned it into
confidence, I love that.
How did the kids react when
you went back the next day?
- They were kinda used to it,
but some people still were asking like,
"Why are you wearing your hair like that?"
I was like--
- Why you wearing your
hair like that, right?
(audience laughing)
That's what I would say.
I love it that.
Your video, though, has
inspired so many people,
including my guest,
my first guest, y'all,
she is a Golden Globe
Award winning actress,
and the star of Blackish.
The last time I saw her she was singing,
"A Moment Like This" at
the American Music Awards,
it was awesome.
Say hello to Tracee Ellis Ross (clapping)
(audience clapping and whooping)
(upbeat soul music)
- I almost fell!
- Oh my god!
- Look at Promise! Look at Promise!
(audience clapping and screaming)
She's so beautiful!
Promise, you're my dream!
- Get up here!
- Promise, come here!
- Come here!
- Yes!
(audience clapping and screaming)
(Promise crying)